I'm Jeremy Brock
welcome to the BAFTA and BFI
international screenwriters lecture
series for 2013 I was on the BAFTA Film
committee and discovered I was the only
screenwriter who'd ever been on it and
after I got over the shock I decided
that the best I could do for my
screenwriting brothers and sisters was
to set up a lecture series in the name
of BAFTA and we were able to bring the
BFI in on that this year we've got a
fantastic lineup we start with David s
Goyer we end with Richard Curtis and in
between we have Hossein Amini Susannah
grant and Tony Gilroy these are serious
heavyweights from the UK and from
America you will be inspired by these
individuals it's taken us a couple of
years to get Susannah here but we are
delighted that she's finally speaking
people will know Susannah primarily for
Erin Brokovich standout film of its year
but also for in her shoes and the
soloist and I think what marks Susannah
route from other writers is her ability
to create incredibly complex anti-heroes
screenwriting is a profession dominated
by men and Susana brings a very
particular perspective and is able to
write women into lead roles with an
integrity that simply comes from her own
I think she writes herself in her movies
rather beautifully there's something a
little bit unsettling about talking
about screenwriting because it implies a
degree of confidence that I honestly
never ever have when I approach it there
was only one time in my life in which I
approached the writing with screenplay
with any degree of confidence it was the
first screenplay I wrote and I was 9
years old
one day my fourth-grade teacher teacher
mrs. Robinson showed up in the classroom
with two eight millimeter cameras which
now is not a big deal but at the time
was radical and revolutionary she said
she was going to that she wanted us to
put away all our books she was dividing
us into two groups and each group would
spend the week making a movie of our own
creation as soon as mrs. Robinson had
announced this project I knew exactly
what I needed it to be
I knew the movie I needed to make it was
as if this magnum opus had been sitting
in my psyche unhatched you know like a
giant ball of methane gas underground
just waiting to be erupted into the
world I I felt it all I needed was 12
warm bodies willing to do exactly my
bidding and that's what I had so day one
I sit down with my group with a fully
realized script that I had spent all
night the night before writing this was
obviously pre computers so all I had
mine was my one handwritten copy and the
only way to share it with them was to do
a dramatic reading so I began page one
smeller ella by Susannah grant I
proceeded to read them seen by brilliant
seen my version of the Cinderella tale
in which rather than being held back by
her lowly station and the cinders on her
face she was afflicted with a crippling
case of body odor naturally the success
of this project lived and died upon my
total control so I seized it I did
everything I directed I did costumes I
start naturally
it's entirely possible that I could have
been more generous and sharing the
responsibilities but I knew if I went
and gave props to somebody else they
would just do it wrong and I'd have to
redo it anyway so what was the point
this was it I had found my thing I
didn't mention this was winter well it
was winter which on the east coast of
the United States is also known as cold
and flu season so on the sixth day of
that week I woke up sick that's okay I
told myself we were well rehearsed as
long as they run through it once or
twice we will be absolutely fine so game
day rolls around I'm not a hundred
percent but the show must go on so I
rallied and I got to school and I get
there and there's my prints and there
are my ugly stepsisters everybody's
ready and I'm ready to roll and someone
comes up to me and says um Susanna yes I
said well well while you were gone we
kind of made a few changes I had not at
the time heard the term page one rewrite
but that is what they done left to their
own devices this ragtag bunch of social
misfits had thrown away everything I've
done and replaced it with dreck I looked
at this new script and thought this is
impossible
I can't possibly act this not a problem
they had also recast I was out and that
was my first rewriting experience so
what on earth would possess me to even
consider a field that not only runs the
risk of that degree of humiliation and
abuse but actually guarantees it it's in
the Writers Guild contract what was I
thinking
if you're me and you're 13 you go to the
movies and you see this
I want you to get up now I want all of
you to get up out of your chairs I want
you to get up right now and go to the
window open it and stick your head out
and yell I'm as mad as hell and I'm not
going to take this anymore
I want you to get up right now shut up
go to your windows open them and stick
your head out and yell I'm as mad as
hell and I'm not gonna take this anymore
things have gotta change how many
stations is this your size excuses I
know it was to lose 11 hey don't take
this anymore then we'll figure out what
to do about the depression and the
inflation and the oil crisis where you
going oh hey let sunny take this anymore
that's Network if anyone doesn't
recognize it and if you don't go home
and watch it immediately because I think
when you're buying a ticket to a movie
when you're buying a ticket to you know
fast and furious 37 or whatever you're
buying you know you're buying a race and
you're buying a thrill and a few laughs
and you're buying Vin Diesel's and
remarkable biceps and all that but
beneath that I think what you're really
buying is a collective emotional
experience that's increasingly hard to
come by in our culture and as a young
person that's what kept me going back
night after night after night so that
became a tangible dream for me a life in
movies and from where I lived in rural
Connecticut at the time it was a
thoroughly impractical impossible dream
there was a small issue of my one
attempt at it having been an absolute
abject and total failure but here's a
secret I have learned in 20 years at a
screen as a screenwriter failure is
constant for everyone and I mean it
everybody fails at this all the time not
just screenwriters but I think anyone
who tries to illuminate the human
experience in an authentic way
so the question then is how do you reel
yourself back from failure in a public
way how do you fall on the right side of
that knife edge and I guess what you
need is a little bit of wisdom and
honesty to look at something you've
written that feels false or boring or
derivative or in poor taste or
bullshitty or inauthentic to you and
just play not good enough and say to
yourself I bet I can do better you have
to be clearer you have to be simpler and
richer and that's difficult a really
good tool for that I've found is working
with good people film is of course a
collaborative art and yes sometimes
those collaborations are like shotgun
weddings of mismatched souls and the
whole thing goes awry and everyone walks
off in a huff vowing never to talk to
each other that can definitely happen
but what can also happen is that you end
up working with enormous Lee gifted
collaborators whose input elevates your
writing above and beyond what it would
have been had you just been working on
your own I want to share with you one of
my favorites it's seen from Erin
Brokovich why don't I take you out to
dinner to apologize for my rudeness
huh you give me your number I mean I
already got your address so you can't
get away huh
and I'll call you up proper and I'll ask
you out and everything you want my
number I do I do want your number which
number do you want George George now I
like the way you say that George uh well
how many numbers you got oh I got
numbers coming out of my ears for
instance ten ten yeah that's how many
months old my baby girl is you got a
little girl yeah yeah sexy huh how about
this for number six that's how old my
other daughter is eight is the age of my
son two is how many times I've been
married and divorced sixteen is the
number of dollars I have in my bank
account eight five oh three nine four
three that's my phone number and with
all the numbers I gave you I'm guessing
zero is the number of times you're gonna
call it hey how the hell you remember
your bank balance you're off the top of
your head like that see that impresses
me
dead wrong about that zero thing maybe
okay arguably not a poorly written scene
however Aaron Eckhart's falling to his
knees and then on his face at the end to
me is my favorite moment in the script
and that was all him that is what you
get when you work with people everyone
has a unique voice everyone has his or
her own you know personal penguin song
and maybe that song is one that millions
of people will respond to and find
interesting and if that's the case
you'll go on to be JJ Abrams and that's
wonderful or maybe it will only
captivate a few and that hat is
wonderful too
the popularity of your unique voice is
not what matters what matters is staying
true to it writing in the voice that is
uniquely yours there's a letter Martha
Graham wrote to Agnes DeMille that I
keep in my office in which she talks
about this unique expression she writes
if you block it it will never exist
through any other medium and be lost the
world will not have it it is not your
business to determine how good it is nor
how valuable it is nor how it compares
with other expressions it is your
business to keep it yours clearly and
directly to keep the channel open and my
favorite part of the letter she says
there is no satisfaction whatever at any
time there's only a queer divine
dissatisfaction a blessed unrest
I do feel enormous gratitude for the
privilege of being a writer for being
able to exist in that state of divine
dissatisfaction it is an enormous
blessing that I do not for one moment
take for granted thank you
I want to know really you doctor there
about the unique voice and that you know
that's what comes through in all of your
work I wonder if you write films given
the eclectic nature of your films but I
wonder if you write films that you want
to see well the problem is I want to see
every movie so that's not really fair
but you know what I think I do do is I
think I write myself into everything
they're always I don't can't believe
nobody's called me out on this yet but
probably because they're always played
by different actors actresses and their
scenarios are different but I've just
really just written myself over and over
in lives I want to live you know it's
just it's just fantasy over I think I I
think I write the things I want to
experience you know because for six
hours of the day you're by yourself
you're in the room that's your reality
it's like this bonus life you get a
whole second existence and then on the
next one you get a third existence do
you have favorites in your in your back
catalogue favorites of my own you're
right oh I like them all um that's the
only thing you look back on is the thing
that the things that disappoint any time
I've protected my job more than the
script I've regretted it I protected my
job as a writer and I protected my job
as a director and both movies suffered
for it okay tell us more about the
distinction between the writer and the
director I mean you've worked with some
incredible directors but with all of
them do you have a different way of
writing as you're writing for with Joe
right if you're writing with Curtis
Hanson if you're writing for you know
who is Soderbergh I mean is it a
different process do you feel
differently about it do you or do you
just write and then hand over and you
know I think it's a the dance is being
collaborative being open and also being
protective of what you've written I
actually think it's a very smart thing
when you start working with someone to
really write down your intentions with
the the movie and and keep them because
you're going to get a million ideas and
a lot of them will be good and some very
good ideas might divert you from that
original intention if you really don't
have it firmly your head and it's it can
be blinding you
no you can be working with someone who's
made twenty brilliant movies Joe Wright
directed a script I wrote called the
soloist and he he brought a very
different sensibility to it you know I
live in Los Angeles and he doesn't
obviously he lives here although I think
he may have moved there actually he
didn't at the time and and the movie is
a lot about some very real social
problems mental health issues
homelessness and the outsider
perspective is a valid perspective and
the insider perspective is a valid
perspective and I think the movie has a
little a little of both I really liked
the movie it doesn't look like what I
thought it was going to it has more of a
I think it's a bit set more set back
from from the story than I had imagined
it do you feel is there a conflict for
you when you're particularly in your
adapting from real life as you have done
memorably with her and and with the
soloist and you know do you feel a kind
of constraint from the fact that you're
dealing with somebody's real life and
you can't kind of mess with the facts or
are you okay with dramatizing it was a
sort of thing to learn and I learned it
on on Darren I had spent a fair amount
of time with her and come to like her
immensely and then I sat down to write
her and having only written you know
fiction fictional characters up until
then I suddenly didn't feel the freedom
you need to feel I didn't feel like God
with this character I didn't feel like I
could do whatever I wanted because there
was somebody who knew her better and I
really felt like I needed to know her
better than anyone else and I finally
decided I just have to I have to think
that there are too Ariens there's the
real Aaron and then I'm making up this
Aaron and I will just take it on faith
that my respect and affection and
understanding of her will make them
pretty close to each other and and that
worked very well I found that if you
decide you're going to be very very
truthful as opposed to very factual
you're going to end up with a better
script there is there's a real
difference between being truthful and
being factual for you but you had a
really surreal beginnings your first
screenplay
your first produce screenplay was was
for a Disney film right well that's
inherent that's that's a whole different
process there were three of us that's
like boot camp and you know they think
there's a little sign outside Disney
that says you know check your personal
artistic ambitions at the door you are
making a Disney product here and I mean
do not forget we got to sell a lot of
plush so that's a very different
experience it was but let me say it was
great
hard work we rewrote every scene minimum
35 times it was just over and over and
over and so it was great experience I
don't I don't mean to talk it down but
it was definitely building a Disney
product as opposed to feeling like you
are bringing your own creative
expression to something
are you a researcher oh yes yeah I've to
a fault
you know you sometimes you can realize
okay I don't actually need to do this
much research it's just time to get to
work but yes I like to feel like I I
think the thing is you got to feel like
you know something so well that you can
kind of find yourself in it you know I
mean I I read a bunch of books about
schizophrenia I read a few written from
people who struggle with schizophrenia
because the idea of writing a 55 year
old african-american schizophrenic
musician there is no cross section
between him and me on paper and yet
until you can find that place where you
and the character are the same I find it
hard to write it
Eileen brush McKenna who is hello Eileen
brush one of your guests here this
evening he wrote of course the wonderful
Devil Wears Prada here somewhere
I was doing one of these screenwriters
lectures a couple of years ago and
somebody asked you know if there was a
kind of magic formula to screenwriting
and I said the very memorable yes it's a
spinny chair yeah I have quoted her many
to happen you sit for long enough and
hope that the script will be will be
will will get
do you have a similar formula or a
similar you know kind of secret tip you
can give us we say go well well the
problem of asked me chair is that it
makes us way too big to just be sitting
in chair so allene said to me not too
long ago well what I've done is I've got
a standing desk and I said well hell I
gotta get myself a standing desk of a
lean has one so I quickly ordered the
standing desk and now we're both
standing at our desks feeling like wow
alright so I'm not you know dying and
calcifying and turning my ass into giant
pillow and umm and then I went her one
better and I got a treadmill under my
desk so now I walk with five miles a day
writing the whole time and my husband
came up and then in the evening of
course you need to add a glass of wine
to it so my husband came up and into my
office and he hadn't seen the treadmill
you he came in and I also work in total
darkness and all he could see was the
glow of the screen me walking in you
know like pajamas and running shoes
drinking a glass of wine like you
realize this this is a crazy person just
wanna let you know them gosh you see you
came here for a tip that's great I just
outed me yeah just just to be serious
about it do you think that there is it's
interesting cuz with you know there is
oft in these screen writers series there
is often a combination of American
writers and British writers and there is
definitely a sense particularly with
comments like a sweets chair and I know
that with American writers you you've
you have a feeling that you if you work
for long enough and you work hard enough
you can make as you know do it do a good
screenplay with the British writers
there is often more of a sense that your
genius you know you are that you either
have it or you done I don't know anyone
who comes up with something really
wonderful without a lot of hard work you
have to keep at it you have to be hard
on yourself you have to you know I have
a great friend who is she's she's
wonderful and just horribly vindictive
and always has a list of people
Pilsner backup list they're the people
if she drove over them she would put the
car in reverse and back up to make sure
they were dead so she raised her when
she finishes his script she actually
puts the title page she rewrites the
title page same title by whoever the
archenemy of the moment is and reads
through the script as if it's written by
someone she wants to fail so badly and
looking for the things that she could
pick apart and and if if it can be
written if it's something she can read
through pretending it's written by her
enemy and she can't hate it she thinks
it's probably good enough I mean that's
how hard you have to be on yourself I
think as tips are coming fast and
furious write it down okay let's have
some questions please just wondering if
you could say anything about having
children the creative process as a
mother um just briefly and particularly
with the you know unpredictable
interruptions how do you manage that I
would like to say oh it has nothing to
do the truth is I think parenting is a
very creative act it does gobble up in a
very gratifying wonderful way a
tremendous amount of your creativity and
and you have to I mean I find that I
have to then sort of I have an office
that separate my children have never
hung out in my office
they have occasionally come and silently
done their homework there but it's its
own space it's its own zone I for a
while I had them on my screensaver and I
had to change my screensaver
I felt kind of cruel but it would just
you know it's it's my own little space
you know and and we get a lot of time
together I mean a wonderful thing about
being a writer is that you're in charge
of your own schedule I can get a lot of
work done while my children are sleeping
do you have an advice for dealing with
notes and produces feedback yes I'd say
be open to them it's a it's a hard thing
because a lot of notes are good and a
lot of them are bad it's often hard to
tell in the moment which they are I mean
some really bad one
just glare at you but the thing I try to
do with ones that are bad or that just
feel like oh what are you even reading
that that's your suggestion is I try to
talk the person through their process of
reading that led them to give that note
because something you got to figure the
person was reading and something rung
wrong for them something felt awry so if
you can back the person up to that
feeling and I really will say where did
you first start feeling this in the
script where did you first where did
your mind start to wander and let's go
there and literally open the script and
say was it on this page start feeling
bad here and what did you feel and was
there a line that sent you awry and
don't ask them just to to say how they
were feeling and then you know if that
person feels heard well enough then you
can say ah I see okay well I'll tell you
what I know another way of solving it
but I totally hear and respect the
problem and then and then you can go
solve it your own way but you know if
you if you yeah if you're working with
idiots there's nothing you can do you're
just